it is your mom actually on the phone
right now on the speakerphone right here
i don't know if you can see it hey
what's up
what's up
you say hi
what'd you think of the touchdown today
he said they said what did you think of
the touchdown tonight oh my gosh i'm
just so worn out
it was just outstanding i couldn't even
believe it i was in shock
hey
he knows how to put that ball up and
that phone on it and he got it and kept
trucking
[Music]
chase young is awesome and i know there
had been some buzz for jeremy chin of
the panthers to be the defensive rookie
of the year i think chase young won the
award yesterday with his performance in
the victory over the 49ers and and he
was holding that ball walter payton
style remember how peyton used to wear
that oh yeah that was before your time i
remember i was i was there you've seen
the highlights yeah but but it was just
incredible and the explosion he has like
when i saw him run to the end zone i'm
thinking maybe they should find a way to
get this guy on offense from time to
time because uh he could do it deadly he
could run over you he could run through
you and he could run past you but here's
washington coupled with the giants
losing at home to the cardinals
washington pulling the upset
in arizona over the 49ers
washington is looking good and i said
weeks ago if they go with alex smith
they can win the division yeah alex
smith was was injured yesterday we have
to watch that cap dwyane haskins came in
but they held on they now have a 71
chance of winning the division after
yesterday's victory they still have the
seahawks to go but then they have the
panthers and eagles after that the
giants have a tougher road with the
browns and the ravens coming up so
could be washington winning the nfc east
unless the eagles can capture some magic
here down the stretch and oh it could
come down to week 17 that could be a
candidate
for
our sunday night game washington and
philadelphia jalen hurts keeps playing
like he has
maybe that'd be even more compelling
than steelers browns yeah i i don't know
about that but it certainly could be
compelling no doubt and washington
what can you say i mean the defense is
almost winning games single-handedly
right now what they're doing it's i mean
it's special
that front four can change a football
game around just as good as any any in
football uh and if that quarterback
takes care of the ball they'll be in it
again just about anybody
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports